speed addiction I'm here to talk about
uh well actually you guys and your
addiction to speed because I asked you
what you wanted to see for this Hazel
devlog and well
look at this fancy stuff popping up
because I got a new editor
it's uh yeah pretty cool gonna
definitely make more videos now right so
it's been quite a while since I last
made a Hazel devlog last time I think
when we released our last game for the
bottom Tech game Jam which I'll have
linked up there uh that was like the
last devlog I think in fact I don't even
think I really spoke about that game
much I don't know I don't know it's all
been a blur I've been focusing on like
other videos doing some work kind of off
screen that you'll see very soon just
not being a good YouTuber you know
sometimes I gotta switch gears and be a
software engineer or I'm going to run
the company that kind of stuff the rest
of the team though have been working
very very hard um there's some really
really exciting stuff coming out for the
second half of this year we're almost
ready to release
hazel2023.2 which is like our second
release for the year I think really the
truth is I'm just overthinking these
devlogs a little bit I just need to hit
record and make it happen I'm sure I'll
come up with something interesting to
say hopefully a bit of a risk there what
if I don't oh well I'll just delete the
video uh so whilst I would like to
update you kind of in detail into what's
actually been happening behind the
scenes uh and I need to shed some light
into what the hell I'm doing I'll
probably make a video later this month
talking about that because you guys
wanted to see some performance
bottleneck discussion
yes no I'm just kidding I like that too
by the way I want to quickly mention
that threads is a thing I have a little
threads account here and my kind of plan
for Threads is to hopefully treat it as
just like a really chill kind of Hazel
devlog and I guess other projects I work
on as well so definitely follow me there
if you want to see like more casual
updates as to what's going on with hazel
because obviously it's easier for me
just type something on my phone share a
photo or something rather than making a
video right so uh what I have over here
is a fairly recent version of Hazel um I
think this is in my yeah Dev renderer
2023 clean kind of uh check out of Hazel
I have a lot of checkouts of Hazel
actually let's just quickly see how big
my Hazel folder is all right there we go
266 or 265 depending on you know tomato
tomato uh gig 189 000 files right yeah I
definitely need to clean that up this is
a fairly recent version of Hazel meaning
that I don't think there are any other
performance improvements that have gone
into that and what I've got here is the
latest game that we shipped Saving
Captain Chino just a little coffee
delivery in a war zone type game you
know the genre um and what we can do is
we can actually so this is like the root
directory of the game with the launcher
and everything but if you go into the
actual Saving Captain Chino uh folder
here this is like the folder with the
executable so what we can actually do is
we can just grab this path and feed it
in as the working directory to Hazel
runtime by the way if you guys want
access to Hazel and you want to support
its development patreon.com we've got an
automated system now where you can just
get access yourself so in the past
people used to send me messages I would
take like up to a week to reply and then
I'd give them access manually now you
just go to get.hazalange.com so
basically as soon as you do it you just
get access if you want to follow along
and play with hazel and learn from it as
well as you know support the team
support the development then that's kind
of I guess like the sponsor of this
video and thank you so much for your
support huge thanks to Hazel for
sponsoring this video alright so here in
the working directory you're just going
to paste that in
um and now we can just launch this I've
got it in release mode probably
shouldn't do any like benchmarking or
whatever in debug mode unless you're
like optimizing debug which is
technically a thing because you
sometimes you don't really want your
debug configurations to run too slowly
anyway so here we have the game this is
running now I do want to quickly point
out actually quick disclaimer I don't I
haven't I've actually tried this yet but
I'm sure there will be problems because
this is kind of like you know like if
you shipped a game on Unity 2021 or
whatever and then you're trying to just
play it with the unity 2022 kind of run
time or 2023 actually what year is it
like there are obviously changes there
and I'm just like I'm not actually even
loading this in the editor I'm just
playing the runtime so we'll see what
happens here hopefully it doesn't crash
but it seems to be working I want to
kind of mute it I wish we added
something to mute the game kind of
in-game all right I've got my volume
mixer here so if I hit play game
okay we've got some uh sound here let me
just mute that right all right okay so
yeah here's the game this is quite a
wild terrain generation thing all right
if we hit Ctrl F3 we can kind of see the
performance so it looks like it's around
72 FPS here which is a little bit lower
than I feel like lower than the the
actual shipped copy which is fun I mean
this is a release build not a disk build
there's some optimization that goes into
a disc build but this does feel kind of
slow if we just take a look at the
timers really quickly here though we've
got the render thread at three
milliseconds the main thread of three
milliseconds and this is 20 milliseconds
okay that's a bit weird maybe we just
got a weird frame but it looks like it's
kind of jumping if I leave it running I
mean it's settling on 144 maybe I just
got like one dropped frame where I tried
to load an asset or something okay so
1467 okay so this looks like other
standard frame so we've got the render
thread here at 6.9 milliseconds we've
got the main thread at 3.7 uh 144 Hertz
is my monitor which is why we're kind of
locking at this I could run this without
vsync in fact I will because that will
just be a little bit better
um so let's just go over here and make
sure that vsync which actually gets read
in from here but we can override it I
think
if we do vsync equals false here that
will just overwrite the actual kind of
tiering settings file which is like our
configuration file um all right let's
take a look at this
okay so we spawned beneath the ground
which I'm guessing is just a consequence
of the wrong run time because that
doesn't seem to happen in the retail
version ah keeps happening okay I
spawned above the ground I literally had
to run it 20 times I think like
something in our C sharp scripting API
must have changed or something physics
related I don't know what it was but I'm
happy to get this spawn
um okay so if we take a look this is I
guess without vsync um let me just let
it run for a bit so 200 FPS ish let's
just kind of take a take a deeper look
here so main thread three milliseconds
we're under thread four
um we're spending five on the GPU so I'm
these timers are a little bit offset
obviously because all the devices are
running in parallel well actually I
guess main thread is running in parallel
so render thread and the GPU is its own
device so that's kind of running in
parallel as well uh GPU weight 1.54
milliseconds so if there's any time here
at all it means that we are waiting on
the GPU to do something like we the CPU
cannot continue until the GPU like has
finished which could possibly stall the
main thread but that also depends if the
main thread has stuff to do or not you
can see here though it's waiting for the
render thread so it doesn't so from kind
of reading these timers what we know is
that ultimately we are GPU bound like
the GPU is the bottleneck here because
the render thread which is on the CPU
that CPU thread is waiting 1.54
milliseconds doing nothing except
waiting for the GPU to finish its work
whereas it took only 2.84 milliseconds
to run so CPU only just means the actual
C plus plus code running on the render
thread how long did that take empty
weight is how long we had to wait for
the main thread which is nothing which
is basically how much of this time was
spent simply doing nothing waiting for
the GPU to finish its work because we
can't kind of continue to the next frame
we're being held back by the GPU and you
can see the main thread is also waiting
for 1.26 milliseconds because its
workload is lower than the render thread
the render thread is taking more time
but again that looks like it's a
consequence of this because the actual
main thread time here actually I wish I
had like a without waiting I guess
because this I'm presuming in includes
the actual waiting for render thread
time but either way cpu-wise we seem
pretty okay here maybe the render thread
is a little bit slower but it's really
the GPU here that's dragging us down
what it also means is that theoretically
we could give the main thread more work
right because if it's waiting it's doing
nothing so 1.26 milliseconds worth of
work can be put onto the main thread
with no consequence to the overall frame
time or frame rate and with the render
thread 1.54 milliseconds worth of work
can easily be put on there as well so
that's good because when you're thinking
about like Optimal for a game and
obviously this is really difficult to do
for engines right because if an engine
is meant to be like a general thing like
as in you're making something like Unity
which you know don't really think that's
what we're trying to do here with hazel
but in a way it is like hazel can be
used to make I guess any kind of game
maybe not like super heavy
photorealistic games you know like
Unreal Engine 5 but in terms of like
genres you know I don't really see any
limitations there and so obviously you
can't really look at these numbers and
be like oh yeah every single title in
Hazel like is GPU bound or is render
thread bound therefore we have 1.26
milliseconds of work but maybe we could
take some stuff from the GPU even and
just put it on that thread maybe there's
a computer doing some kind of culling or
sorting or whatever that we could maybe
just put onto this main thread now
obviously the other thing to consider
here is if you really are wanting to add
more CPU work you could kind of think
about well how much of the CPU am I
actually utilizing here and the answer
is well obviously not much we have two
threads here like there's an audio
thread well in physics I believe can run
on a separate thread although in this
build I believe it's not but my point is
if I have like an eight core CPU and I'm
only really using two threads then like
maybe I can use more and as I mentioned
that audio thread because it's so light
like you could almost split that into
two threads in a way like the CPU will
schedule more work onto that physical
CPU core because audio isn't occupying
all of its processing power if that
makes sense so you can kind of really
think about like okay if I do in fact
have something on the GPU that wouldn't
be too slow to move on to the CPU
because of the difference in
architecture then maybe I can just spin
up another thread and have it do an
entire like potential five milliseconds
worth of processing because you could
effectively do that for free again
assuming it's something that can in fact
run in parallel and isn't dependent on
other things that's why I like
ultimately speaking like a job system
like some kind of task graph with
dependencies and all of that that's
really really important for a game
engine because it lets you kind of
distribute that workload where it's
sensible to do so across the hardware
that you have available to you but the
benefit of looking at this stuff is that
and this is by the way we're just
looking at timers can I just point out
that we are just looking at timers if
you guys are building your own tech
there is no reason why you can't just
Implement some timers like maybe the GPU
timer is a little bit harder which I
mean we're not even looking at GPU
timers here though are we these are all
CPU timers that actual 5.26 milliseconds
of GPU time I imagine that is an actual
GPU timer maybe I actually don't know
I'll have to look at the source code but
the rest of these are all CPU timers we
obviously have like deeper profiling
tools available to us we'll take a look
at one of them in a minute but it's just
cool that there's so much kind of Intel
there's so much information we can
gather just by looking at these numbers
that again are like really primitive in
a way right uh there are also some
things up here in the top right uh this
is just kind of like the overall CPU
time the overall frame time and the
overall GPU time again some of these are
one frame out of sync from each other
which is why some of the numbers might
look weird there's GPU memory usage
which is quite a bit because Hazel
doesn't actually compress any textures
at all at the moment which is a bit
weird uh even though it looks like the
majority of our oh I know why yeah okay
so while we're on the topic of this uh
so this buff means buffers so GPU side
buffers we have 2.42 gig of them which
seems crazy but it's actually because in
this like version of The Source Code
just my locally checked out source code
this is going to sound stupid but in
renderer 2D in the 2D renderer I just
increased like the fixed size of like
how many lines and quads you can render
to like 5 million or something because I
needed to visualize stuff for the ray
tracing series and I needed to like draw
many many lines like one for each array
basically and lots of kind of other
debug Graphics which is done through
renderer 2D and so I just added some
zeros like the buffer sizes that's why
they're huge so I think this will be
definitely under a gig usually
because it is quite a bit
um but images you can see why using 1.13
gig and this is kind of like our current
memory usage versus total memory usage
this would be including shared memory
because I think my 3080 only has 10 gig
of dedicated memory um anyway uh most of
the time as there are are over here and
these things Ship by the way if you just
hit Ctrl F3 I don't know if you'll get
all of the details because some of them
I guess require the non-distribution
build potentially but this kind of is
available in any hazel game uh although
the later versions of Hazel are a little
bit more detailed uh anyway I feel like
I went on a random tangent there what
were we talking about right so actually
optimizing this game though see this is
the other thing if you have a game if
you've made a game like with hazel for
example like let's just say this Saving
Captain Chino was a serious game that we
wanted to ship on Steam potentially even
sell and so it was obviously this is the
product right yes we made it with hazel
but clearly our optimization efforts are
for this game specifically that is where
this is really quite useful because then
you can go in and be like yeah that
thing about making like another course
for some work that maybe is even
specific to this game maybe I can do
that maybe I'm not GPU bound maybe I can
move some stuff over onto the GPU do
some processing there or obviously vice
versa I can see that the GPU time is
more here maybe for this game
specifically I can offload some of the
work from there and move it to the CPU
the only thing I would say to that uh is
obviously be careful because if you're
making PC games especially like it's not
like a console like a PlayStation 5 for
example where you know the exact amount
of cores you have you know the GPU
architecture you know everything you
don't if you're on PC maybe on a 3080
with my like what do I have like a 5950x
I think AMD CPU maybe in on that setup
these are the numbers I get and this is
the bottleneck but then on something
else on a different computer or on a
laptop with integrated Graphics up it
could be completely different and that's
where the challenge comes in you kind of
have to balance this and make sure that
you kind of provide a good experience
across the board and that's I think
that's honestly one of the biggest
challenge changes of trying to roll your
own Tech and make your own game engine
is the fact that like the support you
know supporting a wide range of
platforms and a wide range of just
different Hardware even just on Windows
11 or Windows 10 or whatever like
Windows I'm shipping on Windows sure
easy right no because there's so many
different gpus AMD gpus are different to
Nvidia gpus what about Intel integrator
Graphics right you're going to just cut
that market out because Hazel actually
at the moment I don't think runs on
Intel gpus or at least not like and I'm
talking by the way about integrated GPU
it's not their kind of new dedicated
ones but my point is like there's all
this kind of work that has to go into it
and you know we kind of Studio Channel
like we want to ship games on Steam
eventually like that's kind of our goal
right we we're making Hazel and like
it's our passion we love making game
engines and we love working on Hazel but
we do want to use it to actually make
something that we can ship on Steam and
that's a little bit scary because like
we're gonna have to make sure that it
runs on so much different hardware and I
guess that we have the the diagnostic
information available to us to be able
to fix compatibility issues which is
also something that we need to focus on
and that's like plenty of content I
think for devlogs if you guys are
interested in that right now let's kind
of take a look at the second uh
profiling thing so I'm going to keep
this open because I was very lucky to
get a spawn above ground in this version
uh and I'm gonna launch something called
Tracy Now Tracy we used to use optic for
like profiling but now we use something
called Tracy because it's just it's just
a lot better um and so what I can do
here is I've just opened it and you can
see it's already discovered that this is
running this is just on my local like
computer obviously but I can actually
connect this to anything like if I was
running this on a different device even
or on a different computer you can just
connect kind of I guess over TCP so it's
actually really good uh in that so if I
just click on this you can see it
immediately starts running let me just
kind of zoom out here
because it's a little uh fast you can
see kind of in real time like look at
this CPU usage graph like it's just full
on running like in real time now the
performance has dropped a bit uh that's
to be expected because it's obviously
streaming all of this information so you
just have to be careful with that
sometimes numbers will inflate to
unrealistic values because maybe your
instrumentation is just too much which
is why like honestly I don't know why we
haven't done this yet but it's generally
a good idea to add like a different
granularity of instrumentation that
might just be like I just want the
overview meaning like how long does this
take how long does that take but not
like how long does each individual
render like submission take because that
could be thousands per frame and that
can be really really expensive but
anyway if I just uh like hit pause
arbitrarily here if we kind of just open
this up and zoom in a bit uh we can just
yeah start kind of dissecting this
information so I'll kind of zoom in so I
can show you what's going on we have the
main thread up here we have the render
thread over here we have the audio
thread as I mentioned here you can see
it's not really doing much I believe
this little blip here is the actual work
and the rest is it like sleeping and
waiting we have memory usage I guess per
frame as well which is very interesting
uh CPU usage which by the way is Tiny
like 3.3 percent is like the upper bound
here and if we take a look at this we
can also see where we're bound here the
main thread or the random thread and you
can see unfortunately that this is
showing that the render thread is
spending a lot of time waiting that is
obviously a little bit different to the
timers we just looked at why because
check this out we have quite a lot of
functions here 2344 function calls just
in this kind of block that you can't see
that are all obviously instrumented that
are all trying to submit this data to
Tracy so we can take a look at it and
unfortunately that means that it's
slowing it down which sucks and I wish
there was like a better kind of solution
for this this is still like the overhead
of Tracy as far as I'm aware is much
lower than optic which is great but
that's part of the reason why we
switched to it but it's still obviously
not zero or not very very minor because
you can see how much it's blown up this
time
um but either way if we just zoom in a
little bit we can still kind of see what
is potentially slow here and you can see
there's two kind of Parts here there's
the get well space transform Matrix
which I just know from experience has to
go through like and Traverse all of the
parents that you might have for any
given entity and it has to do a bunch of
kind of matrix multiplication to kind of
work out the actual World space Matrix
from all of the local space matrices we
don't do this in a good way currently
like we literally just work it out every
frame from scratch there are much better
ways of doing this my kind of big plan
to speed this up really is just to have
like a separate component that holds the
world space transform Matrix I'll
probably go deeper into that in a
different video look at that coming up
with lots of devlog content but that's
definitely part of the problem because
you can see we have to do that for every
single static mesh that we submit and
obviously like if the hierarchy is deep
which it isn't actually in this game
that's why you're only seeing like one
or two here but I'm pretty sure what
happens is for example every like
hexagonal tile that you saw that made up
the world that actually gets added to
like here is my world old chunk or
something and the reason why it even
does that like I think it's primarily
honestly for organizational purposes
like in the editor it's nice to group
them so you don't have your same
hierarchy just with lots of stuff
because you can just collapse your
chunks and you don't need to see all the
tiles that make up that chunk that being
said though like if we're really talking
about optimization it shouldn't even be
like one entity per like tile like
that's weird as well this was obviously
a game Jam game if we were actually
properly wanting to like develop this
game and optimize it and ship it we'll
probably write like a world generation
system in C plus that just I don't know
batched the geometry together or at
least like maybe would still use
instance rendering which is what it does
at the moment but just wouldn't treat
them as separate like game entities
because that itself adds a lot of
overhead that is unnecessary considering
they're just static meshes that I mean
are also used for physics obviously
because we need to walk on them but
still it's a bit of a different story uh
so that I I would say is probably the
biggest bottleneck um we can also see by
the way I'm going to just close Tracy
for now again really cool really useful
but sometimes if you go too too fine
grain with it it's not as useful
unfortunately I'm gonna have to close
this which is which makes me scared
because it'll probably be hard to get
another above World spawn but if I just
go into runtime layout we have some more
like fine grain timers here uh here it
is it's in this if false block so if I
just turn that on for a bit what this
lets us do is if we go into like scene
and let's just say we wanted to find out
information about that world space
transform
um it is profile this is what adds the
instrumentation but what I can do is H
said scope uh and then there's perf or
timer I don't quite remember the
difference uh perf is what I want so
scope perf and then I can type in a name
so let's just like I don't know copy
this and put it in here so if I rebuild
now with this I'm gonna get an on-screen
timer that shows the cumulative time
that this took right so the total time
that this took per frame so across all
the times that this was called in a
single frame frame how much time did
that take so control of three you can
see there's way more timers now might be
a little bit difficult to see because
some of them are changing oh I've got
another world spawn here's our get World
space transform with zero milliseconds
and only eight calls okay that's the
wrong function unfortunately I'm gonna
have to run this again
um yeah get World space transform Matrix
is what I wanted so this is the guy uh
let's just redo this we'll run it again
I guess we don't have to be above the
ground though to look at these numbers
but still it seems very very fast 0.002
milliseconds but for
4723 calls in a single frame by the way
this is also very concerning 4 700 pulls
to asset manager get asset like that is
a lot uh but it seems extremely fast
like nine microseconds here and two
microseconds like I don't know if I can
trust these numbers I feel like I need
to dig deeper here because
I just don't believe that it's that fast
but it's difficult because I do know
that these like the The Entity
hierarchies here are not particularly
deep so I guess it is possible that like
that is like if there's an early out
it's probably hitting it because that's
a lot of function calls
um and if we take a look at what that
function does I mean it's going to
recursively kind of go through if it has
a parent but if it doesn't I mean it's
still going to have to go through tryget
entity with uuid which is going to try
and find it find the actual entity buy
it like by its uuid because it's trying
to look for the parent but if it doesn't
hit the parent then it just does this
matrix multiplication which would just
be identity times the actual transform
Matrix which also has to assemble by the
way so I don't know that's a bit sus
like as if it's that fast for like 4 700
times to be continued I guess all right
anyway I'm gonna end it here hope you
guys enjoyed this devlog let me know if
you want to see more of this kind of
thing again I didn't really have an idea
I just like did a little poll as you saw
just like list of some topics off the
top of my head uh and we wound up with
this video so honestly if you guys could
let me know what you liked about it what
you didn't like about it if you want
more content like this but maybe I don't
know slightly different or exactly the
same or whatever it may be please let me
know don't forget that you can get
access to Hazel and also help spot its
development by going to patreon and I
will see you guys next time goodbye